would you sensei
why are you doing
I came out to is that my support to the
voices here in down the row of la
against you know okay legal reform yes
of course but more precisely the
travesty that has become the
embarrassment has become Arizona to the
rest of the world last year there was
probably five percent american flights
and narrow i noticed it's at least
eighty percent people carrying american
flights last year it seemed to be very
hostile crowd with flags representing
you know all of south america and mexico
and kind of antagonistic but not this
year I I sense that there's some fear
that they may you know maybe some laws
pending California
I hate the Arizona law because it just
allows so much you know unreasonable
stop and search if they had they have to
refine it they want to make some kind of
all great well refined the damn thing
they're just racial profiling they're
going by the color and they basically
know that the move the majority people
that there that there are going to be
affected our brown people people color
basically my really but it's very
draconian and I think that it's against
the people that are really helping the
country we listed economically and also
I mean I think I did really think it's
racism racial profiling and i think that
there's other ways to be doing things I
don't think everybody's really aware of
what the law actually states but the
reality is is that our federal
government has failed Arizona and
they're experiencing a lot of problems
because of immigration they're just
doing what they have to do to protect
their citizens because there's a lot
there's many branches that have been
murdered on the border from illegal
immigrants
Arizona's got to wake up man yeah hey
how are you get an arrest by Mexican
cops LAPD Magic Man imagine
there is no law okay I don't get it i
just don't understand it we are in the
shadow and working with our papers and
will be being mistreated sometimes my
teachers they are returned alone but is
mark and we send back home in Arizona
Hornet especially hate on the brown
people out please to pull you over if
you're showing the suspect behavior
suspicious behavior of any kind and they
cannot check see you know your idea your
papers or whatever you have stopped the
hey hey just a little bit weak I i think
it's it's outrageous that you should
pass a law like like that does nothing
nothing whatsoever to solve the problem
and all it does is create more I hate
and animosity on both sides I don't
really hate very much fun I think the
new Arizona law is minus information but
there still has to be immigration law we
just can't allow people to just just
indiscriminately come across the borders
and then just because they're here they
should be legal I don't think that's the
right answer I know people that were
being have been here for
15 20 25 years and they can't do nothing
they're actually like being on their own
hell because they can go to the market
the gun can't go get gas they can't go
to school so something has to be done
it's all huge problem obviously because
now we have I don't know how many
millions of illegal immigrants in the
United States and it's it's just it's a
very difficult issue